l'islam de france et que cela devienne
donc un culte organisé avec de la
formation d'imams en france et qu'ils
puissent donc justement clarifier un
certain nombre de zones d'ombré qui sont
problématiques dans notre pays et ça
tout le monde le sait et nous devons
nous y atteler collectivement donc il
est tout à fait sain et ça va tout à
fait dans mon sens que le chef de l'état
rencontre le cfcm à ses fins la
effectivement qu'il n'est pas la moindre
confusion possible entre l'organisation
d'un culte est une organisation
politique
c'est une vieille lune du pouvoir que
d'essayer d'organiser le culte musulman
est ce que concrètement comment le
l'exécutif peut réussir là où tout le
monde a échoué mais l'exécutif ne
réussira jamais seule ce mouvement là
nous avons besoin justement des
musulmans et nous avons besoin de
structuration et le cfcm est évidemment
une part centrale de cette organisation
est donc de ce mouvement futur il ya
beaucoup de propositions différentes qui
sont faites cela se fera dans le temps
c'était aussi une vieille lune de croire
que cela se passera en quelques mois et
en quelques années vous savez la
religion chrétienne la religion juive ne
sais pas non plus structurée en quelques
mois et en quelques années
l'islam en france est relativement
moderne par rapport aux autres religions
donc il faut aussi qu'ils se structure
mais nous devons collectivement la
compagnie en ce sens là et cela
clarifiera beaucoup de choses l'autre
actualité c'est la crise sanitaire et
dans une lettre à jean castex françois
baroin le président de l'association des
maires de france demande la réouverture
progressive des commerces de proximité
pour je cite éviter un retour massif des
clients dans ces établissements à la
proche des fêtes de noël est-ce que vous
soutenez la demande de françois baroin
je soutiens la demande je crois
collective de pouvoir rouvrir les petits
commerces
dès que possible et je crois qu'il faut
éviter vraiment toute démagogie là
dessus personne ne veut qu'il est de la
démagogie
ceux qui pensent que on a fermé les
commerces parce que on voulait les punir
ceux qui disent à dessein que on a fermé
les petits commerces parce que c'était
là que circuler le plus le virus tout
ceci est totalement faux est purement
démagogique
la vérité c'est que nous avons dû
malheureusement fermée
administrativement un certain lieu un
certain nombre de lieux de destination
pour éviter les déplacements petits
commerces ne sont pas ciblés ne sont pas
fautifs ils sont effectivement
malheureusement des victimes
collatérales dur confinement et donc il
faudra effectivement que les petits
commerces rouvrent dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettront et
je sais que
le comprend très bien si c'est un petit
peu plus tard si c'est au tour du 1er
décembre comme nous l'espérons tous ce
sera très bien parce que nous devons
d'abord maîtriser maîtriser l'épidémie
et c'est évidemment là dessus que doit
se focaliser la priorité ce qui est
démagogique c'est de renverser les
priorités et d'inverser cette hiérarchie
là et de considérer finalement que la
priorité ça serait de rouvrir des lieux
avant même d'être assuré de reprendre la
main sur la crise annie terrain mais
c'est ce matin le fait est que les
fédérations de commerces proposent par
exemple qui regroupe 300 300 enseignes
estime que si on leur grève est par
exemple une partie du mois de décembre
et il pourrait perdre jusqu'à 120 mille
emplois 120 mille emplois est-ce que
vous militez aussi comme le fait le
ministre de l'économie pour que le black
friday
cette opération de grandes promotions ne
puisse pas être accessibles à amazon et
que on essaye de préserver une certaine
concurrence avec et les petites
enseignes
oui bien sûr que je privilégie l'achat
dans les petits commerces dans cette
période très particulière
après il faut relativiser le black
friday on n'en parlait pas beaucoup des
années d'avant tout d'un coup ça devient
le grand le phénomène de l'année ces six
ministres une aubaine en anglo saxons
qui a été justement importés par des
grandes plateformes internet comme
amazon l'idée n'est absolument pas de
dire au black friday tout le monde
trouvera pour justement se ruer dans les
commerces
l'idée c'est peut-être plus tôt de dire
amazon décalé et éventuellement sept
dates de soldes importants pour que les
petits commerces ne puisse pas pâtir
d'un manque à gagner supplémentaire à
cette date là ça oui amazon et prend ses
responsabilités là dessus moi ce que je
note c'est que le comportement de
consommation de beaucoup de ménages de
beaucoup de mes proches de beaucoup de
gens que je rencontre dans ma
circonscription change vis-à-vis aussi
des plateformes internet
il faudrait pas croire que tout d'un
coup amazon serait le grand méchant ça
aussi c'est très simple c'est très
démagogique et que les petits commerces
seraient les petits gentil si amazon
c'est aussi utile pour beaucoup de
personnes qui l'utilisent notamment
quand ils n'ont pas des commerces de
proximité
ce qu'il faut c'est de la responsabilité
collective donc oui si amazon pouvait
décaler cette journée du black friday je
ne sais pas s'ils le font
mais je trouve que ça serait un signal
en résidence des cygnes le décale le 1er
décembre et mon moment où on rouvre les
eaux parallèle met en parallèle des
ouvertures pour que effectivement les
gens puissent choisir et qu'il n'y ait
pas justement cet appel à la
consommation soldes et qui viendrait
peut-être l'achat on petit
commerce qui seraient quelques jours
plus tard voilà des innovations un petit
peu de situations exceptionnelles qu'on
pourrait imaginer avec avec des plates
formes comme amazon mais ni ni bouc
émissaire trop facile ni solutions
simplistes sur la réouverture des
commerces je crois qu'il entend bien on
n'est quand même pas sur une ouverture
le 27 novembre mais c'est tout à l'heure
à nouveau nous devons prendre des
décisions collectivement à la lumière de
ce que nous comprenons de la maîtrise
cette occasion de but alors qu'il
parlait au cou du 1er décembre à ce que
est presque bon je fais pas de fausses
promesses et nous avons dit que le rpt
confinement avaient lieu jusqu'au 1er
décembre
si on peut l'avancer je serais le
premier ravi comme je n'ai pas
d'information sur ce qui va se passer je
veux juste attendre que nous sachions
précisément nous sommes aujourd'hui le
19 novembre je vais attendre précisément
quelle sera la situation 27 novembre
pour pouvoir savoir si on rouvre ou non
aujourd'hui faire une promesse
démagogique en disant je veux que ce
soit le 27 sinon rien ça serait pas
responsable et surtout ça serait pas
rendre service aux petits commerces qui
devrait mal piloté leur retour à la
trésorerie leur retour à l'ouverture
alors que ça serait peut-être pas
possible tout à fait le 27 et que ça
serait plutôt autour du 1er décembre
juste un mot quand même pour dire qu on
a l'impression qu'on parle de situation
des petits commerces comme s'ils
n'étaient pas aidés rappelle quand même
que l'état dans ce confinement a mis 20
milliards d'euros dette publique
précisément pour que ces petits
commerces mettent pas la clef sous la
porte le fonds de solidarité est passé
de 1500 euros par mois à 10000 euros
est-ce qu'il faut élargir ce fonds de
solidarité parce qu'on dira bruno bruno
le maire parle de peut-être de ne plus
2le versées en fonction du pourcentage
des pertes d'exploitation puisque ce
serait pas plus habile ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'à chaque fois que nous devons
malheureusement pour suivre la fermeture
de ces commerces il se fragilise
davantage donc au fur et à mesure il
faut renforcer le filtre sécuritaire ne
peut pas seulement faire un
copier-coller confinement par
confinement il nous faut évidemment
l'élargira probablement que si
malheureusement des commerces devait
fermer soit plus longtemps soit à
nouveau il faudra encore muscler ce
dispositif
parce que là on part vers un
déconfinement très progressif on l'a on
l'a bien saisi et l'autre enjeu c'est
évidemment de d'éviter que tout le monde
se précipite dans les magasins que soit
le 27 ou le premier le 1er décembre dans
quelles conditions on va pouvoir rouvrir
les les magasins il y aura des consignes
qui seront évidemment transmise au
moment où nous saurons et la date et les
conditions possibles ça serait une
erreur je crois de refaire ce qui a été
fait au printemps dernier c'est à dire
que du jour au lendemain comme si le
virus n'existait pas allez vous
ressortez et refait et refaites le même
flux de circulation qu'en temps normal
non évidemment la progressivité c'est
d'abord effectivement peut-être remettre
des horaires c'est peut-être
effectivement remettre les horaires
c'est à dire l'amplitude horaire elle
doit être élargie par exemple en tout
cas il faudra qu'il y ait des méthodes
pour que les flux de circulation soient
repris de façon progressive
ça c'est tout je crois de bon aloi de
bon sens chacun comprendra que sinon on
va retomber dans le même piège que le
premier déconfinement s'avère finalement
une reprise d'abord très lente
et puis tout d'un coup très rapide parce
que nous aurions repris la même vie
d'avant donc il n'y a pas de vaccin tant
qu'il n'y a pas de maîtrise absolue de
cette épidémie
nous ne devrons pas à mon sens reprendre
tout à fait la vie d'avant je crois que
ça ne serait pas responsable de tenir ce
discours
elle est dans ce contexte le sénat
entame aujourd'hui l'examen du budget
que vous avez voté vous à l'assemblée
mardi dernier
il ya déjà des chiffres qui ont changé
notamment ceux de la croissance bruno le
maire a revu les prévisions de
croissance à la baisse
est-ce que ce budget pour 2021
finalement il est bâti sur du sable
non il est pas du tout bâti sur du sable
et bâti de décisions publiques qui
seront extrêmement utiles non seulement
pour 2021 mais pour les prochaines
années jusqu'à 2030 on a voté un plan de
relance qui en deux ans va pouvoir
décaissé 100 milliards d'euros pour
bâtir la france de demain c'est tout
sauf du sable c'est quand vous êtes en
ligne avec ses prévisions de croissance
si vous vend ce sont des fondations pour
amener le pays justement vers un pays
plus fort plus prospère plus compétitifs
enfin dans le monde et qu'on ressort de
cette crise non pas comme avant mais
plus fort qu'avant ce qui peut bouger ce
sont les prévisions macroéconomiques qui
sous-tendent effectivement ce budget le
degré de de croissance le niveau de
déficit
l'importance de la dette ça
effectivement en fonction de comment
l'épidémie et à quel rythme l'épidémie
sera endigué en 2021
il y aura une modification de ces
données la feta construction à midi
quand même c'est pas rien dans la
construction d'un budget mais ce qui est
sûr c'est ce que nous votons c'est des
moyens et ces moyens là ils sont votés
en dur le plan de relance de 100
milliards d'euros et va pas bouger il y
aura 100 milliards d'euros sur la table
ce qui va changer c'est potentiellement
la croissance du pays on l'espère la
plus forte possible
d'ailleurs le plan de relance ça doit
permettre d'augmenter la croissance de
1,5 point ça doit servir précisément à
cela pour avoir le robot le plus fort
possible pour pouvoir avoir le plus
d'investissements dans lés créateurs
d'emplois que sur les entreprises pour
que justement les salariés non seulement
perdre le moins possible leur travail et
sont tous puissent en avoir d'autres qui
sont créés avec des filières de demain
et ça se cette nouvelle perspective du
pays concret avec le plan de relance
dans le budget 21 il a lieu que votre
déficit soit 6 à 7 à 8%
il faut pas confondre les perspectives
macroéconomiques ils sont évidemment
mouvante par rapport à la situation
épidémique avec les décisions que nous
prenons qui sont elles franche offensive
éclair mais justement considérant ses
prévisions macro macroéconomique est ce
qu'il est encore crédibles de rêver à un
retour à la normale de l'activité dès
2022 oui je le crois parce que ça
dépendra justement de la pente de la
reprise économique de notre pays
si nous sommes en capacité à avoir la
fin de la crise sanitaire au premier
semestre
2021 et que le plan de relance est bien
engagée dans le même temps c'est à dire
en préparation en anticipation avec les
premiers investissements
nous sommes en capacité à avoir une
économie très résiliente qui peut tout à
fait reprendre non seulement une
activité normale mais même une
croissance d'activité très puissante et
nous pouvons espérer avoir une
croissance autour de 8 points
dès l'année 2000 21 ceci n'est
absolument pas impossible regardez le
troisième trimestre de l'année 2020 il
est très intéressant à analyser
c'était celui de la première reprise
vous avez une relance qui a été
naturellement très forte très positive
on a eu une volonté de reprise de
travail une volonté de création de
richesses très forte de l'exportation
plus qu'avant la crise
moi je crois qu'il ya vraiment une
dynamique de rebond qui est extrêmement
important dans notre pays et vous savez
quoi les chefs d'entreprise les salariés
attendent ce moment là justement pour
travailler non seulement beaucoup mais
aussi de manière juste manière très
marquée comme structure le fait est que
les oppositions vous reproche finalement
d'investir beaucoup de 2 milliards sur
le futur lointain plutôt que sur la
situation d'urgence que nous vivons est
il est vrai qu'ils ont ce milliard
d'euros sur l'urgence en moi oui cela
dit est ce que les prévisions de
croissance n'oblige pas le gouvernement
a imaginé peut-être d'être de renforcer
les dispositifs vis-à-vis des des plus
démunis et peut-être de réfléchir aussi
à des mécanismes de moustache de la
consommation et c'est ce que nous
faisons monsieur c'est ce que nous
faisons nous votons un budget de relance
et nous votons un budget d'urgence le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
numéro 4 d'ailleurs nous avons voté une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive
avec les sénateurs mardi soir a décidé
20 milliards d'euros de crédits
d'urgence
20 milliards d'euros pour six semaines
trouvez moi un budget qui a déjà voté 20
milliards d'euros pour 6 semaines pour
venir en aide à la consommation du
commerce
ce que plus de clairement sais pas ce
qui est le plus dynamique dans votre nom
votre budget c'est plus la politique de
l'offre que vous favorisez plus que la
cosommation les foyers français en plus
épargné pendant la crise que perdu en
pouvoir d'achat vous avez une petite
catégorie de bercy la catégorie français
a réussi à épargner
c'est la grande majorité en fait ya une
petite partie de la population est
passée une majorité passés sont tous
ceux qui ont eu
accès à l'activité partielle mais ça
valait plus précaire et c'est le sucre
est clair qu'il faut qu'ils aient brillé
précaire nous avons voté un budget de
plus d'un milliard d'euros pour les
aider justement sur cette fin d'année
budget que nous avions déjà voté en mars
vous souvenez lors du deuxième projet de
loi de finances rectificative au total
il faut parler avec des chiffres que des
gens comprennent
au total une famille avec trois enfants
aux minima sociaux c'est-à-dire au rsa
depuis le début de cette crise a été
aidée à hauteur de 1300 euros net à
hauteur de 1300 euros nets depuis le
début de cette crise trouvez moi un pays
qui est venue en soutien à sa population
fragile comme l'a fait la france
aucun aucun ne l'a fait de cette manière
là il ne faut pas confondre un public
précaire fragile qui doit être et d
accompagner socialement et c'est ce que
nous avons fait depuis le début de cette
crise avec la grande majorité de la
population qui travaille qui elle a
plutôt épargné davantage mais vous êtes
d'accord que series est alors rassuré
ces français conçurent épargné ils ont
de la peine à réinvestir leur argent et
vous voyez que vous confondez deux
choses vous me dites de de donner des
aides budgétaires à des personnes qui
ont sur épargné ce qu'il faut c'est pas
donner des aides budgétaires s'est
laissé d inciter à consommer que fait-on
quand nous votons une prime à la
conversion
que fait-on quand nous votons ma prime
rénove qui est une aide justement
financière pour qu'on puisse rénover son
logement privés pour qu'ils soient plus
performants énergétiquement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sinon de
l'incitation justement à la demande
comme on dit économiquement de
l'incitation à la consommation et
l'investissement privé qui lui même
ben justement enclencher une dynamique
très positive sur des secteurs
d'activité comme le btp c'est exactement
ce que nous faisons nous incitons à la
sortie de l' épargne mais à des fins que
nous considérons comme utile nécessaire
comme notamment rénover son bâtiment
changer sa voiture pour avoir une
voiture plus propre etc
et puis la consommation vous savez elle
ne se décrète pas elle ne se votent pas
dans les textes de loi
elles dépendent d'un élément important
qui la confiance et la confiance c'est
quoi la confiance et la sortie d'une
crise sanitaire prison et cet horizon là
c'est le vaccin cet horizon c'est savoir
effectivement quand est ce que les
français vont pouvoir définitivement
reprendre une nuit normale pour pouvoir
consommer de façon normale et reprendre
leurs activités courantes et ça vous
savez c'est intéressant de regarder des
indicateurs de confiance qui sont sortis
après les annonces des vaccins ils sont
saouls
plus important et plus positif que les
mêmes annonces du gouvernement et quand
on vous parle de des chiffres un peu
vertigineux de la dette du déficit vous
nous parler du plan de relance 1 et 2
c'est 100 milliards mais quand même un
moment il va falloir s'attaquer à cette
date à ce déficit pour le réduire est-ce
que ça va être possible de le faire sans
augmentation d'impôts comme s'y est
engagé le gouvernement et si oui comment
c'est notre trajectoire c'est pour ça
qu'il nous faut un rebond économique le
plus important possible parce que c'est
cette croissance plus forte que d autres
pays comme nous le faisons d'ailleurs
depuis trois ans je le rappelle c'est
une croissance plus forte qui doit
ramener justement la trajectoire à l'
équilibre alors ça ne se fera pas en
deux ans faut pas raconter d'histoires
on ne rembourse pas 20 points
d'endettement en deux ans ça prend des
années des dizaines d'années nous avons
aujourd'hui l'opportunité de nous
endetter grattements favorable il serait
coupable de ne pas utiliser justement
cette position conjoncturel tout à fait
favorable à la save à dire qu'on fait
mais avec une dette sont peu supérieur à
100% du pib pendant pendant plusieurs
années ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr et elle
se remboursera avec une trajectoire
d'assainissement de nos finances
publiques qui sera sur le long terme
il ya deux manières de faire soit vous
augmenter brutalement les impôts pour
faire rentrer de recettes soit vous
faites de l'austérité pour baisser les
dépenses et vous dites je rembourse la
dette en cinq ans dans un cas comme dans
l'autre vous êtes fixiez le pays
ceci ne serait en aucun cas responsable
en tout cas moi je ne prendrai jamais
cette responsabilité je préfère dire au
pays oui c'est vrai ça sera un
remboursement lent mais serein lent mais
avec les capacités que la france peut
dégager c'est à dire sur plusieurs
années sur parfois plusieurs dizaines
d'années mais oui nous rembourserons
cette dette parce que là où ce serait
aussi responsable c'est à dire que cette
dette qu'ovide elle n'existe pas de
toute façon tous les pays ont dit stands
étaient pour le faire et nous la
rembourseront jamais non c'est pas vrai
cet endettement nous avons des devoirs
par rapport à des créanciers comme les
mêmes ce serait la banque centrale d'un
déficit à 3% et d'une dette à 60%
pendant des dizaines d'années au moins
pendant plusieurs années pour ce qui est
du déficit effectivement puisque la
partie conjoncturelle viendra abîmée on
va dire notre déficit public
effectivement l'endettement sera
supérieure à 60% pendant très longtemps
mais à nouveau il faudrait peut-être
changer de regard sur ces critères dits
de maastricht ou 10 du pacte de
stabilité
il nous faudrait peut-être regarder
davantage si la france est capable enfin
d'assumer son déficit structurel
c'est-à-dire hors crise
la france pour la première fois depuis
trois ans tendez vers un déficit
structurel nul c'est à dire avec un
solde structurel presque positif
nous devons continuer cette trajectoire
là nous devons démontrer aux français
que oui il y à de l'endettement pour
faire face à la crise l'urgence la
relance chacun comprendra
mais en parallèle de sa la france sait
gérer ses deniers publics dépensent
autant qu'il reçoit en termes de gestion
courante et c'est ça davantage je crois
que bruxelles devrait regarder plutôt
que le solde global puisque
effectivement nous faisons face à une
crise qui nous demandent de dépenser
plus que de raison et non c'est
l'habitude ses finances publiques ce
sera forcément un des grands thèmes de
la de la présidentielle de 2000 22
puisque ça avait été mis un petit peu
sous boisseau pendant pendant évidemment
la crise mais aussi avant par emmanuel
macron qui avait finalement révisées
cesser ses ambitions pour ce qui
concerne les la fonction publique par
exemple
mais la fonction publique est un élément
très médiatique en général mais un
élément de la maîtrise du déficit public
faut pas croire qu'on baisse la dépense
publique avec des fonctionnaires
uniquement ça c'est ça c'est un
raccourci on baisse la dépense publique
par des mesures et des réformes de
structure qui peut-être justement
faisant augmenter la croissance au pays
moi je suis beaucoup plus intéressés à
de la dynamique plutôt qu'à de la
suppression pure et simple une fois deux
d'argent public je suis pas d'accord
avec vous je crois qu'on n'a jamais
baissé l'ambition d'ailleurs en est le
seul coup seule majorité depuis des
décennies avoir stabilisé notre
endettement en est le seul gouvernement
est la seule majorité à être passé sous
les fameux 3 % pendant trois années
consécutives en est les seuls à avoir
amorcé cette dynamique là là évidemment
la crise remet un petit peu tous les
compteurs en l'air mais il faudra vous
avez raison en 2022 avoir un discours de
vérité vis-à-vis des français vis-à-vis
des crises de redresser les comptes
publics par rapport à ce qu'il a déjà
fait les gouvernements précédents où ce
gouvernement là je crois qu'il faudra
aussi que les français regardent
chiffres à l'appui qui a été capable de
mieux gérer les finances du dernier mot
rapidement sur budget avant de passer un
autre sujet avec julien il y aura
forcément des budgets rectificatifs un
vu la situation dès le mois de janvier y
en aura un alors je ne souhaite pas je
crois qu'il nous faut un petit peu
anticipé la la suite de cette deuxième
vague
vous savez ce déconfinement progressif
ne va pas s'arrêter probablement au 31
décembre il va y avoir encore des
séquelles pour un certain nombre de
d'acteurs économiques et de ménage donc
il nous faudra probablement prolonger
les crédits d'urgence
aussi en janvier donc il nous faudra
dans le plf 2021 probablement prévoir
des crédits d'urgence pour ces premières
semaines il y aura je l'espère pas avant
plusieurs mois peut-être des budgets
rectificatifs en 2021 mais vous savez ne
crions pas avant d'avoir mal peut-être
que d'ici là nous aurons des
perspectives beaucoup plus réjouissantes
en termes de vaccins en termes de
perspectives de maîtrise de la de
l'épidémie et donc de la crise
économique et sociale qui nous
permettront de ne pas nécessairement
révisé à répétition encore comptes
publics en tout cas je souhaite que ce
ne soit pas sur le premier trimestre
dernière question julien parce qu'ils
nous respectons sur la loi de sécurité
globale alors oui on est on est sur un
sujet extrêmement brûlant à l'heure
actuelle assemblée nationale est en
train d'examiner en ce moment de la
proposition de loi sécurité globale
alors qu'il traite des de la police
municipale des agences de cdd agent de
sécurité mais aussi de la protection des
policiers
d'où notamment cet article 24 très
controversé qui prévoit d'encadrer la
diffusion des images des policiers sur
les plateformes en ligne
est ce que vous êtes favorable à cet
article qui vise à interdire donc la
diffusion des images
quand il s'agit d'un but malveillant oui
parce que vous l'avez bien vu à des fins
malveillantes
est-ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui se
satisfaire avec l'usagé des réseaux
sociaux d'appeler à lyncher un policier
et sa famille à partir d'imagés où on
reconnaît son visage
non il existe déjà dans les textes de
l'eau à l'heure actuelle est
inacceptable il faut le recadrer le
préciser il faut rendre il faut rendre
la le délit beaucoup plus clair il faut
rendre le délit on se dit que ceux des
villes est déjà relativement saint
martin le pr le problème c'est de
comprendre en fait pourquoi le
l'exécutif veut absolument défendre un
texte où il ne s'agit pas d'une dune
matérialité des faits mais d'une
intention et là on en effet le les oies
est assez et plus mouvant là dessus il
ya un juge qui interprète le droit ne
vous en faites pas c'est pas l'exécutif
ni à la majorité parlementaire qui va
décider au cas le cas de l'intention
réelle de la personne qui a filmé qui a
diffusé ces réseaux sociaux nous nous
faisons le droit le juge l'appliquera en
fonction justement de l'indre il faut
arrêter face à une fausse naïveté
dire qu'il est possible sur les réseaux
sociaux d'appeler à lyncher un policier
en montrant son visage
c'est inacceptable les forces de l'ordre
nous protège cette sécurité c'est la
première de nos libertés
alors on peut vivre encore pendant des
années des décennies en un comme le
singe qui se masquent les yeux en disant
oui mais tout ça c'est ça serait
totalement liberticide
mais enfin de quoi parle-t-on on parle
d'aller lyncher d'aller appeler à violer
les filles de policiers avec des images
sur réseaux sociaux ça ça existe
monsieur s'est pas déjà il faut
clarifier c'est ce que propose cet
article 24 d'une proposition de loi qui
est bien plus large puisque vous citez
l'article 24 aucun qui ait beaucoup
d'autres artistes viennent aussi
protéger votre quotidien le mien et ceux
de nos concitoyens ce sera à nous de la
faire merci merci on certain d'être venu
ce matin
[Musique]